[Music]  shortly after you and your brother were  born  your father and I divorced and we each  took one son obviously haha I got second  pick I have a twin brother my brother  [Music]  finally meeting you your discomfort is  al-arian so how are things career-wise  haha great you let these Most Wanted  village just get away you're fired  so so great crashing it I brought you  here to continue the family business the  only is in your blood and the group can  pubs  I left that life behind me I understand  hmm I wonder what this does  holy moley  common villain Mogambo  that's pretty nice  what did you guys do today there's  always a blinder nothing  put my  hello Oh what about that Wow Oh girls  make you learn to appreciate me  differentiate we've been waiting a long  time so what's was it it was so fluffy I  thought I was gonna die  [Music]  [Music]  so you two are villains  ah I mean hello sweetie Oh Vicky  [Music]